Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
您的夏天从家得宝（Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销活动开始。是时候用下一款烧烤架——四头燃气烧烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需199美元。整个季节都可以用仅售49美元的Hampton Bay West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅来招待亲友。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为5月14日至5月27日，仅限美国，受条款限制。详情请见HomeDepot.com/pricematch。
The 2024 World Happiness Report, released in March, had some sobering news for North Americans. The report, which ranks the happiness levels of countries around the world, found that young people in the United States and Canada are less happy than ever before. In fact, Americans under age 30 are so unhappy that they pulled the overall ranking of the United States out of the top 20 for the first time since the report began more than a decade ago. Today we're going to talk with one of the report's editors about its findings and about global trends in happiness. We'll also dig into what psychological research has to say about what really makes people happy. So why have young people's happiness levels dropped in North America compared with the rest of the world?
3月份发布的《2024年世界幸福报告》为北美民众带来了一些令人清醒的消息。该报告对全球各国的幸福水平进行了排名，结果发现美国和加拿大的年轻人比以往任何时候都不快乐。事实上，30岁以下的美国人非常不快乐，以至于他们将美国整体排名拉出了前20名，这是该报告十多年前开始发布以来的首次。今天，我们将与该报告的编辑之一讨论其研究结果以及全球幸福趋势。我们还将深入探讨心理学研究对真正让人快乐的因素有何见解。那么，与世界其他地区相比，为什么北美年轻人的幸福水平会下降呢？
How does happiness change over the lifespan? And what are some of the key drivers of happiness at any age? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Lara Ackin, a distinguished professor of psychology and director of the Helping and Happiness Lab at Simon Fraser University in Canada. Dr. Acknan was a co-editor of the 2024 World Happiness Report and has been involved in the
幸福感如何随生命周期而变化？在任何年龄段，幸福感的关键驱动因素又是什么？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是加拿大西蒙菲莎大学心理学杰出教授、帮助与幸福实验室（Helping and Happiness Lab）主任拉拉·阿克宁（Lara Aknin）博士。阿克宁博士是《2024年世界幸福报告》的共同编辑，并且在过去五年中一直参与该报告的工作。
report for the last five years. She studies the psychology of happiness, including what makes people happy and the emotional consequences of kind or generous behavior. Dr. Acknan was also chair of the Mental Health and and Well-Being Task Force of the Lancet COVID-19 Commission. Dr. Ackin, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. So why don't you start by telling us more about the World Happiness Report? Where did the data in the report come from? How many countries are included? So the World Happiness Report is an annual report issued every year. It's It's a collaborative effort put together by the Gallup organization, the Oxford Wellbeing Research Center, the UN Sustainable Development Solutions, and the editorial board of the World Happiness Report where we really try to summarize the emerging, some of the best quality evidence on the science of well-being, and share updated reports about how people evaluate their lives as a whole.
她研究幸福心理学，包括什么让人快乐，以及善良或慷慨行为带来的情感后果。阿克宁博士还曾担任《柳叶刀》COVID-19委员会心理健康与福祉工作组的主席。阿克宁博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。谢谢您的邀请。那么，您能先为我们介绍一下《世界幸福报告》吗？报告中的数据来自哪里？涵盖了多少个国家？《世界幸福报告》是一份每年发布一次的年度报告。它是盖洛普组织（Gallup）、牛津大学福祉研究中心、联合国可持续发展解决方案网络以及《世界幸福报告》编辑委员会共同努力的成果。我们致力于总结关于福祉科学的最新、最优质的证据，并分享关于人们如何评价自己整体生活的最新报告。
So each issue has kind of one key central chapter year by year that analyzes data, the most recent data from the Gallup World Poll. that provides some of the best snapshots of planet Earth and how people are evaluating their lives these days. And usually each report has kind of a central focus or theme, this year's report being on age, which I imagine we'll get into, and kind of delves into some of the most recent evidence on the topic. And so kind of each chapter might incorporate some of its own unique evidence, but kind of the central theme and kind of the workhorse, if you will, the data that is really influential and allows us to kind of evaluate the evidence from a global stance is that from the Gallup World Poll, because it is an incredible data source providing
每一期报告每年都有一个核心章节，分析来自盖洛普世界民意调查（Gallup World Poll）的最新数据。这些数据提供了关于地球现状以及人们如何评价自己生活的一些最佳快照。通常每份报告都有一个中心焦点或主题，今年的报告主题是“年龄”，我想我们稍后会谈到这一点，并深入探讨该主题的一些最新证据。因此，每一章可能会纳入其独特的证据，但核心主题和“主力军”——即那些真正具有影响力、使我们能够从全球视角评估证据的数据——都来自盖洛普世界民意调查，因为它是一个令人难以置信的数据源，提供了
nationally representative samples of people from over 136 countries around the globe. So how is happiness measured and defined in this report? Happiness is defined in the world happiness report through several different measures, but kind of the key guiding central measure that we prioritize and investigate very deeply in chapter two of the report is people's satisfaction with life or life evaluations. and this is drawn primarily from one central question called the Cantrell Ladder, in which people are asked to imagine their best possible life or their life, excuse me, on a ladder with 11 rungs. Down at the very bottom is a zero, which is where people would say this is the
全球136多个国家具有全国代表性的样本。那么，这份报告是如何衡量和定义幸福的呢？在《世界幸福报告》中，幸福是通过几种不同的衡量标准来定义的，但我们在报告第二章中优先考虑并深入研究的核心指导性衡量标准是人们的“生活满意度”或“生活评价”。这主要源于一个核心问题，即“坎特里尔阶梯”（Cantrell Ladder），人们被要求想象自己可能拥有的最好生活，或者说，想象一个有11个梯级的梯子。最底层是0，人们会说这是他们能想象到的
worst possible life they can imagine. And up at the very top is the 10th rung, basically people imagining their best possible life. And so each person is asked to imagine where they put themselves right now on this hypothetical, 11 rung ladder. How are the samples put together? I mean, it has to be pretty challenging to get nationally representative samples for over 100 countries. It is a large endeavor and one that Gallup, I think, has been committed to for decades now. It is not an easy or cheap endeavor, too. I think every year, the Gallup organization sets out to kind of investigate and reach large fractions of the population that meet kind of national compositions along various dimensions.
最糟糕的生活。而最顶层是第10级，基本上是人们想象中最好的生活。因此，每个人都被要求想象他们现在在这个假设的11级梯子上的位置。样本是如何收集的？我的意思是，要获得100多个国家具有全国代表性的样本一定非常具有挑战性。这是一项巨大的工程，我认为盖洛普几十年来一直致力于此。这既不容易也不便宜。我认为盖洛普组织每年都着手调查并接触符合各种维度全国构成的大量人口。
Now, in some countries like Canada and the United States, in wealthier regions of the world, this is perhaps a little less time and effort intensive in that many people can be reached by phone and by email through online surveys. But in some parts of the world and in rural communities and hard to reach places, this becomes a much more challenging endeavor because we don't just want representative samples of wealthy urban regions, we want representative samples of the world at large. And so the Gallup organization takes great efforts to go to these hard-to-reach places. So Gallup sends their researchers out door-to-door to speak to individuals to really capture the views, the perspectives, the insights of people around
在加拿大和美国等世界上较富裕的地区，这可能稍微不那么耗时耗力，因为许多人可以通过电话、电子邮件和在线调查联系到。但在世界某些地区、农村社区和难以到达的地方，这变得更具挑战性，因为我们不仅想要富裕城市地区的代表性样本，我们还想要全球范围内的代表性样本。因此，盖洛普组织付出了巨大努力去往这些难以到达的地方。盖洛普派遣研究人员挨家挨户地与个人交谈，以真正捕捉世界各地人们的观点、视角和见解，
the world, not just an easy-to-reach locations, but in the difficult areas to reach as well. So for those of us in North America, the big news was the drop in happiness among young adults. Can you talk about that? How are the different levels of happiness? between younger and older adults in the U.S.? How do they compare with the rest of the world now? Certainly. So, yes, one of this year's kind of headline findings that received a lot of attention in North America
不仅是在容易到达的地点，在难以到达的地区也是如此。对于我们北美的人来说，最大的新闻是年轻人幸福感的下降。您能谈谈这一点吗？美国年轻人和老年人之间的幸福水平有何不同？他们现在与世界其他地区相比如何？当然。是的，今年在北美引起广泛关注的头条发现之一
was this difference in happiness across the lifespan and particularly low levels of life satisfaction reported among youth. So usually when we start analyzing the data of previous years of reports, we don't section by age, and so we just kind of see these overall averages. But this year as a result of the theme and age differences in happiness, we kind of split by older adults, middle adulthood, and younger adults.
就是这种跨生命周期的幸福感差异，特别是年轻人报告的生活满意度水平极低。通常当我们开始分析往年报告的数据时，我们不会按年龄划分，所以我们只是看到这些整体平均值。但今年，由于主题是幸福感的年龄差异，我们将人群分为了老年人、中年人和年轻人。
And when we do so, we found that the typical trend in happiness is quite divergent to North America. So specifically, in most places around the world, young adults report some of the highest levels of happiness. And then as people kind of reach their middle adulthood, their 30s, 40s, happiness tends to decline over the lifespan, kind of reaching this nadir, this bottom of the U-shaped curve, if you will, as people are in their 40s, people often having, many people having children at home dealing with stresses of that, sometimes aging parents, sometimes stress at work as people are usually at some of their highest performing years at work. And then as people kind of increase in age through their 50s, 60s, and so on, happiness tends to increase.
当我们这样做时，我们发现幸福感的典型趋势在北美出现了相当大的分歧。具体来说，在世界大多数地方，年轻人报告的幸福感水平最高。然后，随着人们进入中年（30多岁、40多岁），幸福感往往会随着生命周期而下降，达到所谓的“U型曲线”的底部。此时人们通常在家中有孩子，应对抚养压力，有时还要照顾年迈的父母，有时还要应对工作压力，因为人们通常处于职业生涯中表现最好的时期。然后，随着人们进入50多岁、60多岁及以后，幸福感往往会增加。
And so typically the pattern around the world is a U-shaped curve in happiness. This year, when we split the data by age and looked at various world regions, we saw a very surprising finding or a new trend emerging in the data, a relatively new trend, such that young adults, that is those under 30 in North America, driven heavily by the United States, are reporting some of the lowest levels of life satisfaction we've seen for quite some time. And so this typical U-shape that I was just describing, which is consistent when we look at global data just becomes an upward trend in the United States such that young adults are reporting some of the lowest levels of well-being and well-being tends to increase across the lifespan.
因此，世界各地的典型模式是幸福感的U型曲线。今年，当我们按年龄划分数据并观察世界各地区时，我们在数据中看到了一个非常令人惊讶的发现或一种新兴趋势，这是一种相对较新的趋势：在北美（主要是美国驱动），30岁以下的年轻人报告的生活满意度处于我们很长一段时间以来所见过的最低水平。因此，我刚才描述的这种典型U型曲线，在观察全球数据时是一致的，但在美国却变成了一种上升趋势，即年轻人报告的幸福感水平最低，而幸福感往往随着生命周期的推移而增加。
And so this was a pretty striking finding. In Chapter 2 of the World Happiness Report, it often receives a lot of attention because we rank nations by their self-reported happiness levels. The United States this year, as a whole, came in just shy of the top 20. And part of the reason we think that the United States ranking fell so precipitously this year was because the life satisfaction of young adults was really dragging it down. In fact, if we just look at the life satisfaction rankings across countries for young adults, the United States is in the 62nd position, I believe.
这是一个相当惊人的发现。《世界幸福报告》的第二章经常受到很多关注，因为我们根据人们自述的幸福水平对国家进行排名。今年美国整体排名刚好跌出前20名。我们认为美国排名今年急剧下降的部分原因是年轻人的生活满意度确实拖了后腿。事实上，如果我们只看各国年轻人的生活满意度排名，我相信美国排在第62位。
And so it's really pulling down the weighted average of national happiness for the United States. I mentioned in the introduction that you were the chair of the Mental Health and Well-Being Task Force. of the Lancet COVID-19 Commission. Do you think that we're seeing lingering effects on people's happiness from the pandemic, especially among younger people? I think the pandemic has something to do with it. So when I was working with the Lancet's COVID-19 Mental Health Commission, we did investigate the data on mental health and a lot of related psychological well-being
所以它确实拉低了美国国家幸福感的加权平均值。我在介绍中提到您曾担任《柳叶刀》COVID-19委员会心理健康与福祉工作组的主席。您认为我们是否正在看到疫情对人们幸福感的持续影响，特别是在年轻人中？我认为疫情与此有关。当我在《柳叶刀》COVID-19心理健康委员会工作时，我们确实调查了关于心理健康和许多相关心理福祉的数据。
variables. And in fact, we did see some striking trends around the world where some of the most highly impacted individuals, especially in early days of the pandemic, but remained over time as well, were young individuals, especially those with young kids at home and precarious financial situations. And so when we step back and try to understand what is going on with young people, particularly in North America, and that's worth highlighting, Kim, because the previous conversation we were just chatting about with the precipitous drop in well-being in the United States driven by the young is not necessarily a global phenomenon. This is something we're seeing primarily in
事实上，我们确实在全球范围内看到了一些惊人的趋势，其中一些受影响最严重的人群，特别是在疫情初期，但随着时间的推移依然如此，是年轻人，尤其是那些家里有小孩且经济状况不稳定的人。因此，当我们退后一步，试图了解年轻人（特别是在北美）的情况时——这一点值得强调，金，因为我们刚才讨论的美国年轻人幸福感急剧下降的情况并不一定是一种全球现象。这是我们主要在
North America and some Western regions around the world. But in other parts of the world, like Central and Eastern Europe, young adults are reporting some of the highest levels of happiness. And so it's interesting to think about how this interacts with COVID and what might be a more consistent global feature and might be a more localized kind of difference in certain places and how perhaps how countries handled COVID-19, what kind of supports were available through the governments and through local communities. What might be happening in Central and Eastern Europe, I wonder, particularly because, I mean, they're very close to a war zone for a lot of folks. So why are we seeing, and I'm talking about Ukraine, why are we seeing happiness levels high
北美和世界其他一些西方地区看到的情况。但在世界其他地区，如中欧和东欧，年轻人报告的幸福感水平却很高。因此，思考这如何与COVID相互作用，什么是更一致的全球特征，什么是某些地方更局部化的差异，以及各国如何处理COVID-19、政府和当地社区提供了什么样的支持，是非常有趣的。我很好奇中欧和东欧可能发生了什么，特别是考虑到他们中许多人离战区非常近。那么，为什么我们看到幸福水平很高
or there, do you think? I don't know if we have any particular singular reason. I mean, the unique drop in North America and the United States might have something to do with expectations, might have something to do with social relationships. So there might be one thing happening in in North American data that is driving that response and might be something uniquely different in Eastern Europe and Central Europe. And so some of these trends have been slowly emerging over time, not necessarily just recently emerged since Ukraine. But we think it might have something to do with kind of increased new perspectives about
或者说，您认为那里发生了什么？我不知道我们是否有任何单一的特定原因。我的意思是，北美和美国的独特下降可能与期望有关，可能与社会关系有关。因此，北美数据中可能发生了一件事，推动了这种反应，而在东欧和中欧可能存在完全不同的情况。因此，其中一些趋势是随着时间的推移缓慢出现的，并不一定只是最近才在乌克兰事件后出现。但我们认为这可能与人们对
what life might now bring. So previous generations growing up in Eastern and Central Europe may have had limited ideas about what prosperity an individual might be able to have. what kind of promise or opportunities were available to young individuals at the time, perhaps due to government trends or perhaps due to parents or previous generational expectations. But now as the world has become more global, and I think some of these pressures from the government have been removed and people see a more prosperous future, this kind of hope, this optimism and this opportunity might be opening up kind of a sense of optimism and bright
生活可能带来的新视角有关。东欧和中欧的前几代人在成长过程中，对于个人可能获得的繁荣、当时年轻人可获得的承诺或机会可能有着有限的认知，这可能是由于政府趋势，也可能是由于父母或前几代人的期望。但现在，随着世界变得更加全球化，我认为政府的一些压力已经消除，人们看到了一个更繁荣的未来。这种希望、这种乐观和机会可能正在为年轻人打开一种乐观和光明的感觉，
opportunity for younger individuals as they kind of look ahead. and as they rate their current life evaluations in the moment. You mentioned earlier that this was the first year that the report looked at age differences in such detail. Why did you all decide to make age one of the main focal points of the report this year? I think part of it was pragmatic as a response. So some global data on young individuals, especially young adults, only becomes available every few years. And so, for instance, the child youth data available from the World Health Organization, and from the OECD nations is only available every so often.
当他们展望未来时。当他们评价自己当下的生活时。您之前提到这是报告第一次如此详细地研究年龄差异。为什么你们今年决定将年龄作为报告的主要焦点之一？我认为部分原因是出于务实的考虑。关于年轻人，特别是年轻成人的全球数据，只有每隔几年才会发布一次。例如，世界卫生组织和经合组织国家提供的儿童和青少年数据并不经常更新。
And so although we have been thinking broadly about the importance of well-being and younger age groups for quite some time, we wanted to wait till some of the best available data were available to kind of mine and understand. But I think it is also kind of a theoretical question of great interest for the editorial team. Many of us know that some of the best predictors of how people rate their lives as a whole as adults have to do with how they rate their lives, as young adults. And it's not just, I mean, part of it is this direct effect, but part of it is that young, your happiness as a young adult kind of has some interesting predictive abilities on later life success. So for instance, happier individuals tend to earn more money. They tend to have stronger relationships. They tend to be more engaged citizens. And so understanding
因此，尽管我们长期以来一直在广泛思考福祉和年轻群体的重要性，但我们想等到一些最好的可用数据出现后再进行挖掘和理解。但我认为这也是编辑团队非常感兴趣的一个理论问题。我们许多人都知道，人们作为成年人如何评价自己的整体生活，最好的预测因素之一与他们作为年轻人时如何评价自己的生活有关。这不仅仅是直接影响，部分原因在于你作为年轻人的幸福感对以后的生活成功具有一些有趣的预测能力。例如，更快乐的人往往赚更多的钱。他们往往有更牢固的关系。他们往往是更积极的公民。因此，理解
youth well-being was one motivational factor to try to broaden our understanding beyond just the Gallup roll poll data, which often starts at the age of 15. And so this year's report allowed us to kind of look at a younger age through other data sets that were now available at this kind of time-locked period, but also because we were theoretically intrigued by this question as the emerging evidence starts to suggest and has been pointing us in this direction for quite some time that youth well-being might be indicative and important for understanding global trends in well-being, but also global trends in other meaningful variables. Did you find any differences based on gender? I mean, are men and women equally happy in the
青年福祉是一个动机因素，试图拓宽我们对盖洛普民意调查数据（通常从15岁开始）之外的理解。因此，今年的报告使我们能够通过此时此刻可用的其他数据集来观察更年轻的年龄段，也因为我们从理论上对这个问题很感兴趣，因为新兴证据开始表明，并且长期以来一直指向这个方向，即青年福祉可能对理解全球福祉趋势以及其他有意义变量的全球趋势具有指示性和重要性。您是否发现了基于性别的差异？我的意思是，男性和女性在世界上一样快乐吗？
world? There is surprisingly little difference when we look at global data. So when we step back and look at data points from, you know, over 130 countries, there are very minor differences in gender, especially when we focus in on the wealthier nations. There seems to be very little differences in gender across the lifespan. That being said, if we were to dive down into some minutia, you can, in specific countries, in specific regions, and in specific ages, there are differences, some that are predictable and some that are not. But one striking trend is, especially young women in North America, have been reporting some of lower levels of well-being for quite some time, especially since COVID relating to your earlier question. And so that is one gender
当我们观察全球数据时，差异出奇地小。因此，当我们退后一步，观察来自130多个国家的数据点时，性别差异非常小，特别是在我们关注较富裕的国家时。在整个生命周期中，性别差异似乎很小。话虽如此，如果我们深入研究细节，在特定的国家、特定的地区和特定的年龄段，确实存在差异，有些是可以预测的，有些则不然。但一个惊人的趋势是，特别是北美的年轻女性，在很长一段时间内报告的福祉水平较低，特别是在COVID之后，这与您之前的问题有关。因此，这是过去几年受到相当多关注的一个性别差异。
difference that has been receiving quite a bit attention over the past several years. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now, that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务扩展很快。为了保持花蜜流动，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择Google Fi Wireless的原因。即使在蜂巢忙碌时，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需35美元。这可是一个不会持续太久的优惠。立即探索Google Fi Wireless套餐吧。
Plus taxes and government fees, Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. What about differences between people and developed versus less developed countries? I'm wondering how much impact money or financial security has on people's level of happiness. Yeah, there are some striking differences in wealthier nations and less wealthy nations. That is one of the things we pay some attention to in Chapter 2. So I've been alluding to this fact that we rank countries by their self-reported life satisfaction in Chapter 2. near the top of the list tends to be wealthier nations
加上税费和政府费用，Google Fi Wireless在网络使用高峰期不受数据流量降速限制。发达国家和欠发达国家的人们之间有什么区别吗？我想知道金钱或经济保障对人们的幸福水平有多大影响。是的，在较富裕国家和较不富裕国家之间存在一些惊人的差异。这是我们在第二章中关注的事情之一。所以我一直在提到一个事实，即我们在第二章中根据人们自述的生活满意度对国家进行排名。榜单顶部往往是较富裕的国家，
as opposed to countries at the bottom. And one of the main efforts of Chapter 2 is to try to understand what helps explain these global variations and life satisfaction ratings. And gross domestic product or GDP per capita seems to be one of the core explanatory variables.
而不是底部的国家。第二章的主要工作之一是试图理解是什么有助于解释这些全球生活满意度评分的差异。国内生产总值（GDP）或人均GDP似乎是核心解释变量之一。
And I don't think that's ultimately all that's surprising. Wealthier nations are able to often provide a lot of sense of security and opportunity and simply practical goods like clean water to some of their citizens. And so that's extremely important for living a healthy, happy life. But I think there are also other variables in the report
我不认为这最终令人惊讶。较富裕的国家往往能够为公民提供很多安全感、机会，以及像清洁水这样的实用商品。因此，这对过上健康、快乐的生活极其重要。但我认为报告中还有其他变量
that help explain these national differences that are important to highlight too. So in addition to GDP per capita, how people, their healthy life expectancy is a key predictor of countries that are at the top versus the bottom of the scale. So too is some really important social variables, like whether you have someone to count on in times of need and also the level of generosity that people engage in. So I think GDP per capita is certainly a key predictor,
有助于解释这些国家间的差异，这些也值得强调。因此，除了人均GDP之外，人们的“健康预期寿命”是处于量表顶部与底部国家的一个关键预测指标。同样重要的还有一些社会变量，比如在需要时是否有人可以依靠，以及人们参与的慷慨程度。因此，我认为人均GDP当然是一个关键预测指标，
but so are some other really meaningful and important variables as well. Well, I want to talk for a minute or two about Finland. I recently read a news story about that country, which is it almost always ranks number one or very high on the World Happiness Report, and it was first again this year. This article quoted some Finnish people who said, more or less, it's not that they're happy all the time. It's more that they have more reasonable expectations for happiness that are easier to meet. And I just wanted your take on that. To what
但其他一些非常有意义和重要的变量也是如此。我想花一两分钟谈谈芬兰。我最近读到一篇关于那个国家的新闻报道，它几乎总是排在《世界幸福报告》的第一位或非常靠前，今年又是第一。这篇文章引用了一些芬兰人的话，他们说，多多少少，并不是说他们一直都很快乐。更多的是他们对幸福有更合理的期望，更容易满足。我只是想听听您的看法。在多大程度上，人们对幸福水平的期望会影响他们报告自己的感受？
extent do people's expectations of happiness levels play into how they report that they feel? So many interesting tidbits in that question. But yes, so first and foremost, Finland did top the charts again. This year, I believe it's the seventh year in a row. So this year was not an anomaly. Finland seems to be doing something right that keeps them up at the top, along with many of the Scandinavian countries that have consistently been in the top 10. So why might that be? I think there are lots of factors and it's hard to pinpoint just one. But I think moderate expectations matter. So as we talked about the key measure that we use to rank nations is how people evaluate themselves on this canterle ladder from the worst possible life they can imagine to the best.
这个问题中有很多有趣的细节。但是的，首先，芬兰确实再次登顶。我相信这是连续第七年。所以今年并不反常。芬兰似乎做对了某些事情，使他们保持在顶端，许多一直排在前十名的斯堪的纳维亚国家也是如此。那么原因可能是什么呢？我认为有很多因素，很难只指出一个。但我认为适度的期望很重要。正如我们所讨论的，我们用来对国家进行排名的关键衡量标准是人们如何在这个从他们能想象到的最糟糕生活到最好的坎特里尔阶梯上评价自己。
possible life. And so part of that is the objective reality of people are what people are living in, but the other part of it is where people see themselves relative to their expectations. And so if your expectations are relatively modest, if you're not imagining, you know, a gold-plated toilet seat and multiple yachts to travel the world, that perhaps you're a little closer to the top. But if that is your expectation of success in the best possible life, it might be harder to achieve. And so I think there's something there to these more modest expectations. And I also think it's worth pointing out that, you know, although we call this the World Happiness Report, I think a lot of people imagine happy is kind of this joyful exuberant, you know, skipping down the street kind of emotion.
部分原因是人们所处的客观现实，但另一部分是人们相对于自己的期望如何看待自己。因此，如果你的期望相对适中，如果你没有想象那种镀金的马桶座圈和多艘游艇环游世界，那么你可能离顶端更近一点。但如果那是你对成功和最好生活的期望，那么实现起来可能就更难了。因此，我认为这些更适度的期望是有道理的。我也认为值得指出的是，虽然我们称之为《世界幸福报告》，但我认为很多人想象的“快乐”是一种快乐、奔放、在大街上蹦蹦跳跳的情绪。
But because our main metric used in Chapter 2 is really about people's life satisfaction on this imagined or personally relative scale, I think that helps us understand why it's not just people skipping down the streets of Finland, but maybe being content with the lives that they have and perhaps their relatively modest expectations of where they do fall. So there are any plan to change the name to the World's Contentment Report? Would that be more accurate? Yeah, well, something about satisfaction I think might be. But the happiness verbiage does draw people in. I think that's an accessible term that many people kind of gravitate and understand. So moving to the other side of the globe, the world happiness researchers were able to include India for the first time this year. Why is that significant? And what did you find? This year's, yeah, this year's report was the first to be able to examine India, which is an incredible addition because India is one of the world's most populated regions. And so to be able to take a deep dive into this extremely populated country is important for understanding where the world is in terms of global.
但因为我们在第二章中使用的主要指标实际上是关于人们在想象的或个人相对量表上的生活满意度，我认为这有助于我们理解为什么芬兰人不仅仅是在大街上蹦蹦跳跳，而是可能对他们拥有的生活感到满足，也许是因为他们对自己所处位置的期望相对适中。那么有什么计划将名称改为《世界满足感报告》吗？那样会更准确吗？是的，关于“满意度”的说法可能更准确。但“幸福”这个词确实吸引人。我认为这是一个易于理解的术语，许多人倾向于此并能理解。那么转向地球的另一端，世界幸福研究人员今年首次能够将印度纳入其中。这有什么意义？你们发现了什么？今年的报告是第一次能够考察印度，这是一个令人难以置信的补充，因为印度是世界上人口最多的地区之一。因此，能够深入研究这个人口极其众多的国家，对于理解世界在全球
happiness levels. It's also important because this year's report provided by the, provided by the team in India, was able to present some of the first data from a country, a national survey trying to understand older adulthood in India. And so this plans to be a long-to-to-no data set that will be capturing and tracking the well-being of older adults in India. But this is the first year's snapshot. But it's incredible because I think it shows like a large-scale effort to try to understand well-being of citizens around the globe in such a populated area or nation of the world, but also because India has not just one of the largest populations, but one of the largest aging populations in the world. And so we were really excited to kind of see these efforts and
幸福水平方面处于什么位置非常重要。这也很重要，因为今年由印度团队提供的报告能够展示来自该国的一些首批数据，这是一项试图了解印度老年人的全国性调查。这计划成为一个长期的数据集，将捕捉和追踪印度老年人的福祉。但这只是第一年的快照。但这令人难以置信，因为我认为它显示了一种大规模的努力，试图了解全球公民在如此人口众多地区或国家的福祉，也因为印度不仅拥有世界上最大的人口之一，而且拥有世界上最大的人口老龄化群体之一。因此，我们非常兴奋地看到这些努力，
to see what is being learned in such a pretty monumental investigation into the well-being within a nation. What did we learn from that chapter in particular? There are a lot of interesting findings, but I think one of the important underlying messages is that many of the findings we see from higher-level, from higher-income countries seem to be parallel in the data collected in India as well. So, for instance, people with higher levels of education, people who tend to be partnered or married tend to report higher levels of happiness. And while that might seem not all that surprising, data collection needs to expand to other countries and cultures and populations around the world, not just high-income countries to capture how people are experiencing their
并看到在这个对国家内部福祉的相当重大的调查中学到了什么。我们从那一章中学到了什么？有很多有趣的发现，但我认为一个重要的潜在信息是，我们在高收入国家看到的许多发现似乎与在印度收集的数据是平行的。例如，受教育程度较高的人、倾向于有伴侣或已婚的人往往报告更高的幸福水平。虽然这看起来并不令人惊讶，但数据收集需要扩展到世界各地的其他国家、文化和人群，而不仅仅是高收入国家，以捕捉人们是如何体验他们的
lives. And so I think this look into how people are reporting their lives in one of this most, one of the most populated countries in the world is important to see parallels and it's important to see differences where they do exist. Let's change gears for a minute and talk about your research. Most of your work focuses on how being generous and doing things for other people tends to make people happy. Do you have any favorite studies that you want to talk about that can illustrate this? Yes. This is one of my favorite topics, so I could go on for quite some time, but maybe I'll tell you about two. The first was one of the earliest studies we ran, but I think one of the clearest to kind of explain the general question that I'm after. So in one of my first studies,
生活的。因此，我认为这种对世界上人口最多的国家之一的人们如何报告他们的生活的研究，对于看到相似之处以及在确实存在差异的地方看到差异非常重要。让我们换个话题，谈谈您的研究。您的大部分工作都集中在慷慨和为他人做事如何倾向于让人快乐。您有什么想谈论的、可以说明这一点的最喜欢的实验吗？是的。这是我最喜欢的话题之一，所以我可以讲很长时间，但我还是给你讲两个吧。第一个是我们进行的最早的研究之一，但我认为是最清楚地解释我所追求的一般问题的研究之一。在我的第一项研究中，
in graduate school, I had the pleasure of going out on the university campus in the morning hours and inviting people to participate in a short study on what we call just everyday spending habits. And if the people we spoke to were so inclined, they were given, they were randomly assigned to one of four conditions in our experiment, which involved me digging into my backpack, pulling out an envelope that had one of two different monetary amounts inside. So half of the folks were given a $5 bill, the other half were given a $20 bill. And along with the bill that they received were it was a small slip of paper with some spending instructions. And so critically, half of these folks were asked to spend the money by the end of the day on a small gift for themselves. And the other half were asked
在研究生院时，我有幸在早晨去大学校园，邀请人们参加一项关于我们所谓的“日常消费习惯”的简短研究。如果受访者愿意，他们会被随机分配到我们实验的四个条件之一，这涉及我翻找我的背包，拿出一个信封，里面装着两种不同金额的钱。一半的人得到了5美元的钞票，另一半得到了20美元的钞票。随钞票一起的是一张带有消费说明的小纸条。关键是，这些人中有一半被要求在当天结束前把钱花在给自己买一份小礼物上。另一半被要求
to spend the money on a gift for someone else or a charitable donation. And we let them go on their merry way. They did whatever they wanted to do with this money. We asked them to spend it by five o'clock. And then a research assistant called them at the end of the day to see how they were feeling. And importantly, this research assistant didn't know what they had been asked to do or how they had been asked to spend the money. And we asked them in this phone call to report how happy they were feeling. And what we found was that it didn't matter so much how much money people had received to spend. What really mattered for their happiness at the end of the day was who they spent the money on, such that people who spent the money on others were significantly happier
把钱花在给别人买礼物或捐赠给慈善机构上。我们让他们随心所欲地去花这笔钱。我们要求他们在五点钟之前花掉。然后，一名研究助理在当天结束时给他们打电话，看看他们的感觉如何。重要的是，这位研究助理不知道他们被要求做什么，也不知道他们被要求如何花钱。我们在电话中要求他们报告他们感觉有多快乐。我们发现，人们收到多少钱并不重要。真正重要的是他们把钱花在了谁身上，那些把钱花在别人身上的人明显比那些花在自己身上的人
than those who spent on themselves. And this question about whether being generous and specifically whether being generous with our financial resources is something that has fascinated me now for over a decade. And I've really been trying to understand, you know, is this something that those of us living in North America who are fortunate enough to have extra disposable income might simply get to enjoy or whether this is something that is, you know, much more consistent to the human experience, whether it might be something we can see in most countries and cultures across the age spectrum and across different lived experiences? And so we've run a number of studies. I've had the great pleasure of collaborating with people from all around the world. But the other study I wanted to tell you about is with young kids because I wondered, you know, at what age do we begin to find giving rewarding? And so partnering with a developmental psychologist and another social psychologist. We ran these studies where we got toddlers just under the age of two to come into the lab with a parent. And they were taken through a five phase, like very brief. It was just a few minutes, but they saw kind of a small puppet show and they got to interact with the puppets. And so,
更快乐。关于慷慨，特别是关于慷慨地使用我们的经济资源是否是一件让我着迷了十多年的事情。我一直在努力理解，这是否只是我们这些生活在北美、有幸拥有额外可支配收入的人才能享受的事情，还是这在人类体验中更具一致性，是否在大多数国家、文化、年龄段和不同的生活经历中都能看到？所以我们进行了许多研究。我有幸与来自世界各地的人合作。但我还想告诉你的另一项研究是关于幼儿的，因为我想知道，我们在什么年龄开始发现给予是有回报的？因此，与一位发展心理学家和另一位社会心理学家合作，我们进行了这些研究，让不到两岁的幼儿和父母一起进入实验室。他们经历了五个阶段，非常简短，只有几分钟，但他们看了一个小木偶戏，并与木偶互动。
In the first phase, they met a stuffed animal monkey who liked eat it. They found out likes eating treats. Then this child themselves received a few treats. And they were told, they got to eat them. They were just edible crackers that kids really enjoy. And then critically, over the next minute or so, they got the chance to give one of their own treats to the puppet. They got to watch as the experimenter gave a treat to the puppet.
在第一阶段，他们遇到了一个毛绒猴子，它喜欢吃零食。他们发现它喜欢吃零食。然后这个孩子自己收到了一些零食。他们被告知，他们可以吃掉它们。它们只是孩子们非常喜欢的可食用饼干。然后关键的是，在接下来的一分钟左右，他们有机会把自己的零食给木偶。他们看着实验者把零食给木偶。
Or they got to give one of the experimenter's treats to the puppet. So they either got to engage in costly giving or not costly giving. And every time the puppet got a treat, they ate it in a very excitable way. And we wanted to know how the kids felt when they got to give. And so we learned that you can't just ask two-year-olds how happy they are because they say they're happy all the time. So instead what we did was we set up a video camera over their shoulder and we captured their facial expressions. And later we coded these for the extent to which the kids were smiling. And what we found, I think, was really fascinating.
或者他们有机会把实验者的零食给木偶。所以他们要么参与了“昂贵的给予”，要么是“不昂贵的给予”。每次木偶得到零食，它都会以一种非常兴奋的方式吃掉它。我们想知道孩子们在给予时感觉如何。所以我们了解到，你不能直接问两岁的孩子他们有多快乐，因为他们总是说他们很快乐。所以我们做的是，我们在他们的肩膀上方架设了一台摄像机，捕捉他们的面部表情。后来我们对这些表情进行了编码，以了解孩子们微笑的程度。我认为我们发现的结果非常迷人。
So first and foremost, we found that kids smiled more when they gave away treats, to the puppet than when they received the treats themselves. But critically, what I thought was so interesting and exciting was that kids smiled more when they gave, when they gave away a treat that belonged to them than when they gave away an identical treat that didn't. And so what my colleagues and I kind of argued is that even under the age of two, we see some evidence for the fact that people might feel good when they give, and perhaps especially when it involves a sense of self-sacrifice. So what happens when people don't have enough resources for themselves? If you So if you're struggling with poverty or other hardships, can being generous still make you feel happy?
首先，我们发现孩子们在把零食给木偶时比他们自己收到零食时笑得更多。但关键的是，我认为非常有趣和令人兴奋的是，孩子们在给予属于自己的零食时，比给予相同的、不属于自己的零食时笑得更多。因此，我和我的同事们认为，即使在两岁以下，我们也看到了人们在给予时可能会感觉良好，特别是当它涉及一种自我牺牲感时。那么当人们没有足够的资源给自己时会发生什么？如果你正在与贫困或其他困难作斗争，慷慨还能让你感到快乐吗？
I think so. I mean, so I kind of alluded to this in my last question. So I've had the good fortune of working with collaborators from all around the world to try to test this question in places where people might have objectively very little to give. And the short answer is we see that even in places where people and among samples where people are having trouble meeting their own basic needs, they also feel good when they give. And I think one kind of important feature of the work that sometimes gets lost is that people don't need to be giving a lot to feel good about giving. So in many of our experiments, people are giving the equivalent of $2. You know, they're buying a chocolate bar for a sick kid at a local children's hospital or buying a very similar chocolate bar for themselves. It doesn't need to be these momentous donations.
我想是的。我的意思是，我在上一个问题中提到了这一点。我有幸与来自世界各地的合作者合作，试图在人们客观上几乎没有什么可给的地方测试这个问题。简短的回答是，我们看到即使在人们难以满足自己基本需求的地方和样本中，他们在给予时也会感觉良好。我认为这项工作的一个重要特征有时会被忽略，那就是人们不需要给予很多就能对给予感觉良好。在我们许多实验中，人们给予的相当于2美元。你知道，他们为当地儿童医院的生病孩子买一块巧克力，或者为自己买一块非常相似的巧克力。不需要是那种重大的捐赠。
You don't need to be, you know, gifting a wing at the library to feel good about giving. These small acts of generosity seem to be enough to live. lead us to feel good about giving. And part of the reason I think for that is that we're just extremely social creatures. And these small acts of giving in generosity allowed us to build and facilitate and maintain these relationships we have with other people. Let me ask you about another area you've been doing some research in. You published a study recently with another scientist we've had on speaking of psychology, Jillian Sandstrom, that looked at how people feel about reaching out to old friends. What inspired that study and what did
你不需要捐赠图书馆的一个侧厅才能对给予感觉良好。这些小小的慷慨行为似乎就足以让我们对给予感觉良好。我认为部分原因是，我们只是极其社会化的生物。这些小小的给予和慷慨行为使我们能够建立、促进和维持我们与他人的关系。让我问你关于你一直在研究的另一个领域。你最近与我们曾在《心理学谈话》中邀请过的另一位科学家吉莉安·桑德斯特罗姆（Jillian Sandstrom）发表了一项研究，探讨了人们对联系老朋友的感受。是什么启发了那项研究，以及你们发现了什么？
you find. Sure. Yeah, Jillian is a good friend of mine and it was such a pleasure to work on this with her because it was a very clear example of what we joke about as me search, not research, me search, because Jill and I have been friends since we were graduate school buddies and we kind of, she moved to the UK, I stayed in Canada. And although we've had projects to keep us connected over the years, those kind of wax and wane. And unfortunately, because I'm not good at keeping in touch, when projects end, I don't get to speak to her as regularly. And about two years ago on New Year's Day, or around New Year's, I realized that I hadn't spoken to her.
你发现了吗？当然。吉莉安是我的一位好朋友，能和她一起做这个研究真是太高兴了，因为这是一个非常典型的例子，我们开玩笑称之为“自我研究”而非“科学研究”。因为我和吉莉安从研究生时代起就是好朋友，后来她搬到了英国，我留在了加拿大。虽然多年来我们一直有项目保持联系，但这种联系时断时续。不幸的是，因为我不擅长保持联络，项目结束后我就没法经常和她交谈。大约两年前的新年那天，或者新年左右，我意识到我已经很久没和她说话了。
I really missed her. And so I sent a text message saying, I miss you, we should find a new project to work on so we can connect. And originally the project was designed to look at what kind of situations encourage people to reach out to old friends. Like I had taken New Year's as an opportunity, this inspiration, this excuse, if you will, to reach out to Jillian. But as we started exploring this question, we just found that no matter what kind of situations,
我真的很想她。于是我发了一条短信说：“我想你了，我们应该找个新项目一起做，这样就能保持联系了。”最初，这个项目旨在研究什么样的情境会鼓励人们联系老朋友。就像我把新年当作一个契机、一种灵感，或者说一种借口去联系吉莉安一样。但当我们开始探索这个问题时，我们发现无论我们给人们提供什么样的情境，
we threw at people as excuses to reach out to old friends. They were particularly reluctant to do so. And so we've spent the last two years trying to explore whether people have old friends, you know, the people that they care about, but they've lost touch with. And the answer seems to be yes. What excuses people think are valid to reach out to old friends? The short story is not many. the only one that seems that people will endorse is reaching out for a birthday.
作为联系老朋友的借口，他们都表现得特别勉强。因此，过去两年我们一直在探索人们是否还有老朋友，也就是那些他们在意但已经失去联系的人。答案似乎是肯定的。人们认为什么样的借口联系老朋友是合理的呢？简而言之，没几个。唯一似乎人们愿意接受的理由就是以生日为借口进行联系。
And then we tried to find ways, well, we tried to benchmark this reluctance. We found that people are as willing to reach out to an old friend as they are to pick up garbage and talk to a complete stranger. And then we tried to figure out ways to get people to do it. And that wasn't easy. We found one way. But we hit, we had a lot of roadblocks before we found one successful intervention. And what is that?
然后我们试图寻找方法来衡量这种不情愿。我们发现，人们联系老朋友的意愿，和他们捡起垃圾并与陌生人交谈的意愿是一样的。接着我们试图找出促使人们行动的方法，但这并不容易。我们找到了一种方法，但在找到这个成功的干预措施之前，我们遇到了很多障碍。那是什么方法呢？
The successful intervention is. getting people to basically do a warm-up or practice activity. So in one experiment, we recruited about 200 people on a university campus. All of these individuals told us that they had an old friend. That is someone they care about, but they've lost touch with. This is also someone who they think would be happy to hear from them, and they have contact information for. And then one group was randomly assigned to this warm-up practice task where they sent a couple messages to current friends and family. The other half was randomly assigned to simply browse Facebook or any social media they choose. So it was kind of a passive social comparison. And then when three minutes were up, we asked people
这个成功的干预措施是让人们进行热身或练习活动。在一个实验中，我们在大学校园里招募了大约200人。所有这些人都告诉我们他们有一位老朋友，也就是他们关心但已经失去联系的人。这些人也认为对方会很高兴收到他们的消息，并且他们有对方的联系方式。然后，一组被随机分配到这个热身练习任务中，给现有的朋友和家人发几条信息。另一半人被随机分配到仅仅浏览Facebook或他们选择的任何社交媒体。这是一种被动的社交比较。三分钟结束后，我们要求人们
to draft a message to an old friend and we gave them the opportunity to send it. And what we found was in our control condition, very similar to our previous experiments. Only about 30% of people were willing to hit send to send that message they had just drafted. But in the experimental condition where people had practiced for three minutes prior, it was almost double that. It was just over 50%. What are you working on now? What are the big questions you're trying to answer? Well, some of these questions are kind of emerging from this reaching out to old friends question, trying to understand who are the individuals that are most likely to reach out and how people feel when they do. students in my lab are also very interested in multiple forms of generosity, so advice giving,
起草一条给老朋友的信息，并给他们发送的机会。我们发现，在对照组中，情况与我们之前的实验非常相似，只有约30%的人愿意点击发送键发出他们刚刚起草的信息。但在实验组中，即那些提前练习了三分钟的人，这一比例几乎翻了一番，超过了50%。你现在在研究什么？你试图回答哪些重大问题？嗯，其中一些问题是从联系老朋友这个问题中衍生出来的，试图了解哪些人最有可能主动联系，以及人们在联系时会有什么感觉。我实验室的学生也对多种形式的慷慨行为非常感兴趣，比如提供建议、
food sharing, and how that makes people feel. And also, we have a couple projects looking at how people express their thanks to one another and what is some of the most meaningful content and a gratitude message. That all sounds interesting and uplifting, the kind of research that makes you happy to do, right? Certainly. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting. Thank you, Dr. Acknan. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speaking of psychology or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review.
分享食物，以及这些行为如何影响人们的感受。此外，我们还有几个项目在研究人们如何向彼此表达感谢，以及感恩信息中最有意义的内容是什么。这听起来既有趣又令人振奋，是那种让你做起来很开心的研究，对吧？当然。嗯，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这非常有意义。谢谢你，阿克南博士。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请订阅并留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can reach us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wyner. Thank you for listening. To the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 联系我们。《心理学谈话》由李·怀纳制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。